this morning crews in eastern Canada are
cleaning up after extensive damage from
Hurricane durian a massive construction
crane collapsed onto a building in Nova
Scotia Saturday durian slammed Halifax
as a category 2 hurricane in the Bahamas
thousands of people are scrambling to
escape areas destroyed by durian the
official death toll there rose overnight
245 Merrill Barnett's been reporting
from the Bahamas since last week he
joins us from Freeport on Grand Bahama
Island
Erol this is an incredible humanitarian
crisis yeah without question the UN
estimates 70,000 people are in need of
food and shelter and we've been speaking
to many of them the government says its
evacuated roughly 3,500 people
southeastern Nassau it was largely
untouched by the storm but I can tell
you that there is mass confusion as
American groups come in combing through
miles of debris like this to try and
help account for the missing just a week
after Hurricane durian struck the
Bahamas the desperation to escape the
devastation is rising
thousands waited to board boats and
planes headed to Nassau or Florida over
the weekend before this ferry left for
Florida overnight one reporter captured
videos of the crew ordering a vacuous
without a US visa to disembark US
Customs and Border Protection is blaming
the ferry company for ordering certain
evacuees off the boat
CBP officials saying they would have
processed those evacuates
just like they did with nearly 1500
durian survivors from a cruise ship that
arrived Saturday on Sunday we joined a
team of firefighters from the city of
Miami and Miami Dade County as they
search for victims on Grand Bahama
Island delivering aid to those stranded
in the hardest hit areas where would a
good place for us to bring in the middle
of the devastation we found Eva Thomas
staring into the distance holding a
shovel see all the debris lined up in
front of your home yeah this is your
whole life right here right there
everything gone one time Randy and
sylveon Aggie felt dorians I bulldozer
over them as they rode out the storm in
their beachside home we listened as they
use the first-responders satellite phone
to call their daughter for the first
time since the disaster this was very
very bad very bad decision
sounds like there's like a big sigh of
relief and you got each other still and
we have been hearing so many unnerving
stories whether it's the woman who
watched her grandchildren wash out to
sea or the man who held onto a tree for
dear life for two days as Dora installed
now us groups are here helping because
the government is unable to manage this
crisis alone and it reminded everyone
once again this weekend that the death
toll is expected to increase
significantly Gail that's because so
many people are unaccounted for the
story's getting worse thank you very
much Errol Barnett in the Bahamas